[musique]
Je répète, où est l'auteur du meurtre ?
Transports en commun et recherchés dans tout le pays sur scène
Allez dans la grande équipe de héros du ballon volant
Qu'est-ce que tu as fait
[musique]
Commençons ni le salut de l'humanité
Il n'y avait pas de vagues
Je n'ai pas faim, dis juste jaune f
Pourquoi penses-tu que je suis important
[musique]
moi
Hugh fait de son mieux avec Raisa
Je suis fort si je ne protège pas tout le monde
tabous
futur papillon blanc
Je veux être cool Aide les gens avec le sourire
Je pense que je suis un héros
Laisse le moi
tuer avec des amis
protéger les autres
c'est
Ana
non
ana eh abandonne
Il est temps d'abandonner
Zehiro est venu thé
N'abandonne pas c'est chez toi
Nan
mon université de héros le
héros du monde du cinéma
jeu de mission terminé